[Music]
okay so it is now my great pleasure and
an honor to introduce our chief guest
for today will be giving a keynote
address today mr. Dinesh Verma ray I met
him at the promisee party at Eva's that
was organized by India's Ministry of
External Affairs in June this year
focusing on artificial intelligence mr.
morays secretary to the Ministry of
External Affairs and Indian overseas
affairs but what I found also very
interesting in addition to all his
accomplishments in the Ministry of
External Affairs is that he's a very
celebrated author I understand in
Marathi but also in Hindi and maybe
other languages and in addition he has
launched educational projects in his
native town and and so it's really a
great honor to have him here today and I
look forward to your remarks thank you
so much so great pleasure meeting you
I've just arrived from the airport and
sorry to be little late disclaimers
first I'm not an expert you know in AI
so my position is quite safe I'm also
not a representative today of government
any government agency that's why my
intelligence today is going to be really
artificial I I'm not holding any key
some notes yes but really I don't claim
to be a keynote speaker my interest
would be really I am a student I am
quite amazed and I'm no scientific
background no IT background otherwise I
would have used something very high-tech
but I have a deep interest in this
because anything that is game-changing
interest me anything that can really I'm
from a village my father was a farmer I
joined the Foreign Service
perhaps by fluke by chance but my
interest has always been why am I in the
Foreign Service type of a question and
therefore I always try to see whether I
can connect diplomacy to people that's
my focus because diplomacy is not
minister of External Affairs in
diplomacy is not south lock not block
diplomacy is people people of a country
so just like that you know AI or Noah it
has to be ultimately for people and for
the humanity so that is the basic
concern and being a student I you know
read a little bit and if I feel that
this is some game changing thing that is
on the horizon and therefore we organize
this conference in MEA where we had
experts coming from all over the world
and we had some interesting discussions
so that's where I start I am NOT a
skeptic I'm not you know suspicious of
what it will do to humanity though in
the past you know any major
game-changing technology or effort has
always been seen with suspicion you know
every now and then we have we see a
pattern emerge within technology and
society at large that there comes along
a new understanding that man has of
science a new ability to manipulate the
tools in his environment to his benefit
to craft the world around him in a new
dimension and a new possibility that
didn't exist before and such moments
what I call pivot points change
everything they accelerate the evolution
of society accelerate our culture help
us overcome all problems and create new
opportunities there is a paradigm shift
that these pivot points have on society
that becomes undeniable they alter the
course of history forever you know some
of the pivot points in history for
example we learn to walk man discovers
fire innovation of the V we learn to
farm we learn to build we build the
first systems we build railroads
to men realize you can sit in a tin can
with wings and it will fly the invention
of nuclear power the invention of
transistors and silicon chips
the first telephony conversation the
invention of the first computer
the invention of the mobile phone the
invention of smartphone Facebook and now
man marveling at its potential to be at
the cusp of creating something in its
reflection yet other than itself and
intelligence that is artificial
intelligence unlike what Hollywood or
fantasy novels would sell you the dooms
day scenario of AI taking over I am here
to rather paint a much different
grounded view in AI see liberation I'm
not though I'm not quite 100% sure while
coming here I also had this thought of
this great book by Francis Fukuyama
called the post human society this I
read sometime in 2013 and Fukuyama has a
very interesting view of the world some
of you might be knowing he says that we
are perhaps on the cusp of being a new
species
humanity post human society is the name
of this particular book the developments
in biotechnology genetic engineering
robotics precision engineering eyeteeth
all this is changing humanity to such an
extent that we are perhaps likely to
become a different species on together
that's his conclusion if I remember
correctly and therefore we need to have
a larger mechanism to bring some kind of
a basic regulatory framework for this
that's the you know just as we have for
nuclear weapons we have for you know
weapons of mass destruction Alcoa's
ation which creates I particularly
believe in the fact that it's good to be
a humanity rather than being something
else because it's a great responsibility
now to remain a human human and in that
journey I am actually not sure as to how
a I will play
out--it's rolls will it help us in
achieving an new station in the
evolutionary process or will it changes
completely I think that AI is not
specifically mentioned by a Francis
Fukuyama if I remember correctly I had
not heard this word you know maybe two
years back I had not heard this word
myself so that being the case perhaps
what he says is now actually you know we
are perhaps facing that moment so it's
very interesting and very fascinating
and very challenging moment for all of
us you might wonder why I bring up this
point it is because ai2 is a
revolutionary technology one that shines
a mirror right in our face and for it to
truly to be adopted we must ensure it
permeates our culture in a way that
touches the lives of billions
particularly billions is a word which is
very suitable for India because once I
was asked being a diplomat how would you
describe India and actually well one has
thought a lot about one's own country it
often becomes difficult to encapsulate
it in one sentence or few words so I
said India is 1.3 billion stories and
when I look back at I always think
that's a very fairly intelligent answer
because if you see the diversity
language culture folk songs people
costumes heritage it's absolutely
fascinating playground for people in AI
because AI has to deal with very complex
things including I think intuitions and
how do we really come so you know India
that way is a very fertile ground for
this particular purpose let me clear I'm
not here to be prophetic or simply talk
in abstract terms as if I am pitching at
you a new idea I guess you have already
bought it to the idea which is why we
are here I am here to get specific about
how AI can affect daily life and what
can be done to ensure the proliferation
of
this great technology so it can truly
rise to its best potential knowledge is
best utilized if it becomes a part of
daily life that is the true movement of
pivot point for any technology where it
goes from being exclusive to becoming
all inclusive Facebook and extremely
exclusive community at first meant only
for Howard grads truly took truly took
off and saw its rise when the Mehta
wallah down the street could also be on
the same platform and trust me he knows
how to use Facebook just as well as
anybody else in this room we as we as
human tend to him instead to be blind to
see well as anybody else we as human
tend to be blinded to see there recites
in everybody a spark of brilliance
whatever you can name it social
brilliance or maybe singing brilliance
or talent and that billions comes in
varied form for some it is in writing a
great deal some it is creating
algorithms for some it is building a
company for some it's PhD from IIT or
USC and for some it is knowing how to
run the best metal shop in the entire
Chandni Chowk and yet all of us are
brilliant and intelligent in our own
ways if we are supposed to truly think
of benefit of AI to the society we have
to first internally accept everyone is
brilliant just because Lalaji from
Chandni Chowk who owns the best metal
shop in Delhi never learned how to write
his first line of code and print hello
world on C++ doesn't mean that he lacks
the intelligence to make AI a daily part
of his life our friend simply speaks
different languages his transaction
between the scientist and Lalaji breaks
down if the scientist puts the onus on
Lalaji
to figure out how to use AR or to know
the difference between convo
convolutional neural net and artificial
neural net it's sort of
like Lala ji asking a programmer whether
to fry the bottom first or the quiche
mesh for the halwa to retain the
slightly child child but not burnt
flavor we just want the halwa and we
want it to taste good when good
technology doesn't get adopted it's a
communication breakdown between the
scientists and the masses I believe that
anything that we are doing at this
particular stage in our evolution has to
be useful to the masses which really
represent nothing but the humanity at
its core this happens because many a
time futuristic technology they tend to
become egalitarian reserved only for the
elite few so even if something may have
a great impact the masses learned to shy
away from such tools self subscribing to
the impression that a certain tool or
technology may be outside their
comprehension or that it's something
meant to be in a research lab and often
it is very it is the very creators who
end up isolating their own creations
when they become subject of elite
praising only and with that ignore with
that technologies which could have had a
wonderful impact end up dying a slow
painful death versus mass adoption I
remember that akio morita in is made in
Japan also I had made some very
interesting points about how we give a
cassette recorder of a particular size
survived and how we did not because they
thought that they wanted to have an
exclusive exclude exclusive product
while everybody else in the world had
adopted a particular standard and you
know producing mass creations so I'm
here to give you a context of how AI can
go on to become a part of daily life of
Indians and hopefully give some
perspective on why it is extremely
critical for AI to proliferate down to
the very grassroot levels of the society
outside of standard corporate
environment as well it is my hope as we
start digging deeper that the ideas and
viewpoints I put for
helped inspire the audience members to
truly think outside the box for a
proliferation to happen at the highest
level we must design a high tools such
that one is able to use them without
requiring any prerequisite tools or
knowledge or even skills let me give you
an example
there was a time designing a website was
something you hired a coded for coder
for it was a luxury afforded only to the
few lucky ones who were either affluent
enough to have a website or were
literate enough to navigate the world of
CSS HTML our dreams favors there was a
certain set of knowledge one required
before one could have their own website
this changed however with the advent of
wigs
Squarespace WordPress without having any
knowledge of HTML you could drag and
drop elements onto a canvas and build
out a website built out store the common
entrepreneur with no special computer
skills could get an online store up and
running in minutes
all because tools like fixed and
Squarespace made creating a website easy
and fun website in today's day and age
isn't about a website it's about having
an identity the onus is on all the
stalwarts of AI present here in this
audience to truly think how can we
highly functional drag and drop tools
with such easy user interface that it
could allow someone with zero coding
skills to deploy AI based apps sure a to
machine learning and apt exists but I
challenge and implore you to go further
I am envisioning a platform where a
child could learn how to make an AI do
an application even before he writes
code simply by using drag-and-drop tools
on a canvas what we are doing here is
taking the fear out of air making it
accessible for proliferation to happen
any of the scary aspects of AI need to
be eliminated we have to make an actual
part of our lives we have to make it fun
and relatable I'd like to propose an
extremely practical use case for
that is sure to hit every Indian heart
shortly after I'll follow it some uses
case used cases within the health care
sector a recent friend of mine see my
aunty you all know si Monty went through
the experience of hosting a shoddy and
they were since then I have wondered how
about an AI driven app for managing the
shoddy bringing together all the vendors
the flower guy the caterer the tent guy
the transportation company the wedding
decorator the baker the band wala the
deejay the lighting guy do you know how
many variables one has to manage you are
consistently taking calls you have
multiple points of contacts one is
texting the other is calling someone
typical confusion chaos and confusion of
Indian marriage prefers email the other
prefers what's up you end up explaining
the same thing over and over again ten
times in ten minutes what if I could
manage all these relationships from one
single app understand and the bottle
understand the bottlenecks see if
everything is running on schedule I
would even have my invite list list on
the same app along with the card
printers I could have people RSVP
through the app and the AI could predict
based on traffic conditions what the
flow of guests is going to be what the
dietary preferences of our guests are
what the most appropriate frequency to
roll out the appetizers during the
wedding to make sure they don't dry up
truly this can be broken down into an
algorithm the USC folks out here are
going to enjoy this you can even take
into account air humidity and moisture
to understand the effect of sponginess
of the Dhokla and the frequency at which
they need to be rolled out to make sure
the few factor of our doula is of the
highest caliber possible based on real
time guest flow I could also understand
if the letter Koala invited more guests
than us that is their koalas by running
a cross comparison report of the RSVP
origination the data doesn't lie
who thought C want a new taunt
to her and aunt is neut on to her
would-be son-in-law would be the data
doesn't lie
this is such a simple yet practical use
of data science this is hard core data
science on the back end but it would be
a dream come true for anyone who has
managed a wedding in the house your
balloted of delays bottlenecks from any
vendor along with having a complete
vendor and market place for best rates
for shoddy vendors in your area you
could even arrange a pundit or a priest
if one needs to be needs to we could
even have backup vendors ready in place
in case someone was going to fall
through I am sure you could even have a
backup groom put that mediate a use case
we omit out of this India is a land of
weddings so let's get people married
more efficiently I think particularly in
the IT sector it's not very efficient or
it can't run very efficiently I am sure
you are wondering if this is the best
use of your expensive computer science
degree
well the reason why I chose to go with
such an example is because it does
something wonderful it makes a less
scary packaging is very important about
use case packages concept concept within
yes such as process improvement process
management efficiency response risk
mitigation predictive analysis and data
analysis into a very non scary non
version of virtual shaadi manager
ultimately AI is not about Peter nor
weeks of the world or the very
respectable Harry Shum Shum Shum I don't
know how to pronounce Indian languages
actually are far more phonetic and
they're therefore far more scientific
when you relate them with how it is
written and how it is pronounced that's
can also I'm told help in the IT it's
about humanity as a whole
it's about enriching one's life in a way
that's why I can't write my name
correctly in any standard you know
scripts that are available because it's
Nana schwa nobody can pronounce it
correctly even in India
outside mirages forget about them doing
it horses it's about humanity as a whole
it's about enriching one's life in a way
that it isn't pretentious but truthful
to the stories of billions of people for
see my auntie for that brief moment in
time the shaadi becomes her universe and
if AI can succeed in making that small
little universe about brighter place
where things just fall into order order
we are then succeeding to give another
analogy smartphones all of us present
here know how to use them and all we
require to do so is room temperature IQ
the fact that I don't have a complete
understanding of the components inside
the actual iPhone does not act as a
barrier to my utilization of the iPhone
I can use it just as well as anybody
else
a similar paradigm has to emerge with an
AI for mass adoption moving on and to
change the mood I would like to get into
another into the healthcare sector I
believe some people here are actually in
the healthcare sector India is a
uniquely positioned at the current
movement for health care overall we also
stand to produce a tremendous amount of
data that can contribute towards
research and may say real-time
behavioral data for correlation between
different ailments and lifestyle choices
the HIPAA healthcare laws of us design
with the best intention in mind of
securing the privacy of the patient have
made electoral electronic medical record
a miaar industry in us a fragmented and
disparate system that is slow to
innovate so we must go beyond the
traditional model India hasn't model
India hasn't still adopted the concept
of EMR but in many ways this fresh start
or rather blank canvas is a chance to
learn from the mistakes and successes of
others before us and truly innovate I
would like to propose a two way EMR
system where the patient and doctor both
have the ability to input data let's
take a moment to think majority of EMRs
right now don't have the ability to have
a two-way conversation platform between
the patient and the doctor
let's say you had a patient come in for
cancer treatment as he starts his
treatment he is given a standardized app
that he downloads which is tied up with
his EMR number much like another number
and he's put on the cancer regimen but
as a part of his health care treatment
he's also required to voluntarily log is
quality of sleep his daily activities
daily diet this one's for the data
scientists in the room whose fields are
already turning now this data is being
collected through a mobile app on the
phone and every time the patient goes
for his chemo treatment the doctor is
able to generate analysis in real-time
to see what are the correlation between
lifestyle choices and prevalence of
certain types of cancer this information
is currently not possible in real-time
as a two-way EMR logging system which
allows the patient to log their
lifestyles habits and give doctors
real-time access into patients life is
something that hasn't been deployed
doctors can see what is the correlation
wouldn't diet and certain type of cancer
are certain types of cancers more
prevalent in certain zip codes are we
seeing an increase and I would grow
outbreak of a certain subtype of cancer
coming from certain geographical region
with certain lifestyle choices I call
this an active EMR where the patient
actively takes part in logging their
daily habits their calorie count their
activities of the day quality of sleep
imagine the leap healthcare can make
when this data is cross collated in
real-time we are cutting through all the
red tape of gathering gathering such
data you have an active population of a
billion plus participating in a lifetime
study that evolves and collects data
that goes well beyond just the confines
of elaborate drones have become a
controversial topic once mind
automatically resorts to drone strikes
and drones as amusing of man's latest
invention in making a new efficient
killing machine
on the contrary though I'd like to shine
some light on some use cases that have
major impact on healthcare
imagine a rural area where a mother
requires a life-saving medicine in the
middle of the night cueing drone
this is not futuristic or experimental
the scientists in the audience are aware
that barring certain exceptions machine
vision algorithms and drone technology
are already mature enough to perform
this feat similarly given urban traffic
an ambulance is on the way to see a
patient who's called in for
life-threatening allergic reaction the
ambulance gets stuck in traffic making
it impossible to reach the patient in
time however utilizing the utilizing
drone delivery a med pack with an EpiPen
and a video tablet is dispatched the
drone arrives at the scene while the
ambulance is still trying to make its
way through the traffic the medic in the
ambulance is videoconferencing the
family of the patient walking them
through the steps of administering the
EpiPen saving the life of the patient in
a scenario where few seconds would have
mattered drones and ER can be the
difference between life and death we all
fight our own battles and sometimes
technology can be confronting a
comforting tool to remind us we are not
alone I would like to propose in the
application of AI and helping addicts
quits substance abuse how about an AI
driven app to help you quit smoking
gambling drinking imagine having an app
that helps you quit drinking every time
I think it will be very useful in
Bangalore every time you are going out
with your friends alert the app you will
be out with your friends the app could
also use location data to see if you
have stopped by a bar and how long you
are there at bar it could keep sending
you push notifications reminding you to
not give in to peer pressure and the
promises you have made to yourself call
it a timed intervention if you keep
ignoring the push notifications not even
checking them it could even generate an
automatic call with a pre-recorded voice
message from your friends reminding you
why you want to quit it could even alert
your closest friends to call you for
support and remind you to stay strong
all of us struggle against some kind of
demon and/or the other and all we need
to be reminded at the
right times is we are not alone that
struggle safety is primary concern of
our public transportation in fact
Bangalore transportation can do a lot
with the use of application of Pune ons
whatever take people out there the
traffic seems to be getting from bad to
worse so I think you need to come
forward to find out some complex
solutions to these issues and AI perhaps
can be of great use their safety is
primary concern of our public
transportation utilizing pose estimation
sorry facial recognition and machine
vision we could monitor our buses
especially with the algorithmic
sensitivity turned on to high during the
night and upon detecting suspicious
behavior the nearest police station
could be live-streamed the visuals from
the inside of the bus CCTV to assess
whether a threat is real or not we can
save lives we can keep our women
children and been safer I know there
will be a time where we will predict
epidemics before they happen and save
millions of lives I know there will be a
time when our City Planning would leave
by generations utilizing behavior
patterns and congestion patterns I
envision a day where a child in a rural
area will be able to remotely program a
drone and use it for smart farming
farming because agriculture has a huge
you know fortunately culture is a huge
opportunity for AI believers and being a
very complex country as it is you have
agriculture strange agricultural
patterns weather patterns marketing
channels available not available
offseason on season drought years no
drought years we can really take this
forward in a huge way in agriculture is
concerned whether that time happens
today or 10 years from now is dependent
on our willingness to understand
as innovators that we must make AI
accessible fun and easy the applications
of AI for benefit of social good are
endless but the bottom line stays it
must proliferate to the very grassroot
levels of society we must learn to speak
the language of the common man and truly
make them see AI as a friend not a foe
oh that's my more or less thoughts on
the topic I'm not sure whether it makes
any sense
as I said I'm a student and very soon
I'm going to retire and AI is one of my
focus areas particularly higher
education so that's why you know my
interest in this topic I think before we
embark on a huge journey we also need
some good awareness in society and that
kind of education short term medium term
long term courses is I think need of the
time and that's where perhaps I might be
focusing some of my energies so I'm
willing thank you so much for inviting
me and all of you thank you so much for
being so patient I am NOT a doctor I
can't give remedy to all the patients
but let's work in this endeavor together
and if I could be of any assistance then
your journey I'll be there to help
assist support and work together thank
you so much
[Applause]